you know when I found out that there was
a new full trailer for Batman V Superman
my first instinct was you know what
don't watch it you're planning on seeing
the movie anyway there's nothing more
you need to see and I really should
learn to listen to my instincts the new
Batman V Superman trailer what did I
think oh look I was skeptical about this
movie before if you watch my channel you
probably already knew that but now I'm
actually genuinely not looking forward
to it anymore it's not so much that what
i saw was bad although some parts of it
were low i'll get to the breakdown parts
of it later but as an overall thing this
is the kind of trailer that I just hate
because what it looks like it feels like
is it broke down the movie here's Act
one here's Act two here's the big
climactic fight at the end won't you
come and see that was like will you
showed it to me already now the trailer
starts fine we open Bruce Wayne Clark
Kent talky little antagonistic you kind
of wonder do that you know who each
other are then you kind of get that vibe
maybe they don't maybe they suspect I
like it I like the banner and then Lex
Luthor walks in when Jesse Eisenberg was
first cast I was like yeah what that
could work cuz he can do intelligent but
you know what else he can be he's
annoying boy is he annoying in this you
know it's a really hard needle to thread
it to craft a character who is annoying
to other characters in the film but not
annoying to the audience I think they
missed the mark if that's what they were
going for here yeah and yes I get that
this sort of you weird personality like
over-the-top oh you do not want to make
a fight with that guy thing that he's
got going on is probably an affectation
so people don't realize how sinister he
really is you gotta taste it out a
little bit when he has his line with
Lois Lane later but you know what I
don't care even if it's an act I still
don't want to be stuck with this
annoying little twerp he reminded me
more of mr. Mitzi's public that he did
of lex luthor we've got all this desert
desert stuff and i suppose i'll also
address sort of the 52nd you know just
extracted clip that was the desert stuff
with Batman hang in there and then
Superman comes in and rips the mask up
that's a dream I'm calling that right
now that that's a dream the whole feel
and vibe of the thing is like this no
this feels off not in like bad movie way
but like it is intentionally ramped up
man looks way too ticked off so either
they've completely given up Superman
being heroic and no blood all or this is
a dream and I figure it's a dream i
think the capper for me was at how in
the new show there's like this really
quick images of these big flying buggy
looking things I'm like this is Batman's
nightmare is what this is humans
worshipping this alien and then more
aliens come down and wipe out the human
race it's a dream which takes these few
glimpses that we've gotten in early
trailers and everyone was really
intrigued by always Batman and the
desert what's with that duster that's
really cool and you know we were all
extrapolating thingy how could it be
well now I feel like I know what it is
so now I don't care anymore and it's the
same thing with what I'm gonna call
dooms ro maybe it's Tuesday maybe it's
bizarro who knows who cares it's
whatever they did with Zod's body we now
see it and it looks like the abomination
from The Incredible Hulk with less
personality and again they killed the
moment from the earlier trailers that
really a lot of speculation and
anticipation was built around witches
that moment were Batman you know gets
his grappling hook in zooms away as a I
laser blast hits the wall behind him and
we're all its supermen actually trying
to kill him because that would have
killed him was but we see this dooms
Arros face go red so he's about to go
with the ideas like okay great so it's
his eye beams trying to kill Batman it
was never Superman in the first place
now we know that and now we know that
that intrigues gone and just I kept the
whole thing up they destroy the
introduction of Wonder Woman great now I
don't have that to look forward to
either thanks so much trailer I mean I
have a feeling we'll probably see her
maybe as Diana Prince before she shows
up as Wonder Woman I really kind of hope
they don't just draw out of nowhere but
they obviously have not seen her before
that so this is probably where she drops
in combat ready and everything goes and
honestly it was a cool moment wish I
could have been in the theater when I
saw for the first time I just hate this
kind of trailer it reminds me of that
Terminator Genisys trailer where they
gave away the entire plot now it's not
quite that bad because everything it's
showing me in this case none of it is a
big twist it's all stuff that we either
knew was coming or we had fairly good
reason to believe was going to be
happening but they've now blown the way
is going to be presented I
wasn't going to this movie expecting
didn't you know have my mind blown with
twists that I didn't see coming but I
was expecting to go in not knowing how
the various elements that I know existed
it we're going to be presented and going
to be played out and now I feel like
well now I know how all this stuff is in
there I know what lex is gonna be like
to the point that I'm now already
annoyed with him I've now seen dooms ro
they shouldn't have shown that at all I
now know how Wonder Woman drops into the
scene the mo look here's the lineup of
all three take now that thing that that
better not be the climactic fight but I
know in my heart of hearts it is you
don't show the set up for the climactic
fight in the trailer stop it am I still
gonna go see it yeah probably mainly
because I am more interested in the
other movies that are going to build out
of it than I am in this I am more
interested in the Batman movie that will
be made or the Suicide Squad or really
pretty much anything else but this movie
self I'm not really looking forward to
it at this point it may be that means
i'll have more fun maybe i'll go in
it'll really have the potential to
surprise me I kind of doubt it though so
latest trailer for Batman V Superman
have you seen it you probably have seems
like everybody has at this point I'm
getting this out I'm a little late to
the game because like I said I struggled
with whether or not I should watch it
wish I hadn't did you see it you
probably did what were your thoughts
whatever they were drop them down in the
comments and let's talk about it until
next time this council is adjourned